ken just coming back do you want to talk
to you just personally you know you've
been around the royal family for a very
long time
uh obviously protecting them and they're
very well protected today
when you look at william harry who
you've known since they were tiny boys
and they're in the procession
but there's no real contact between them
that we've seen even in the 10 days very
little eye contact no apparent talking
it seems to be a temporary truce to put
their grandmother first but underneath
it this rift that continues to rage
what do you make of that and what do you
think charles could possibly do to try
and get through all this
i i appears you're absolutely right you
know there is clearly a rift but this is
very much ceremonial there
on duty and and that's a very important
word for those of the royal family
because it's all about a sense of duty
i mean harry had no choice he had to be
there
you know the fact that that he was in
uniform today was on the assistance of
his father but you know the the the er
initials were removed from i thought
that was churlish
if you're gonna let prince andrew have
er on his shoulder
then why wouldn't you let harry i i i
don't hate i i don't disagree with you i
i i do think it was a bit cheerish
because you know this is a state event
and let's be honest that harriet himself
is the the only member of the royal
family recently that was actually fought
a campaign in afghanistan
and and he he alone should i think been
allowed to do that with with all the
incidents it seemed a bit churny i mean
i've got no truck for harry's behavior
in the recent years but this was his
grandmother he did serve his country
with great valor
two tours of afghanistan um and we've
already had the rao about the uniform to
start with where andrew was given
dispensation to where he is and then
eventually harry was allowed away but to
then remove the er and have it sent him
without the initials of his own
grandmother i just thought don't be
churlish and actually don't fuel his own
innate sense of victimhood right just
don't give him an excuse to moan again
but i i'm not i don't know exactly what
the protocol on that was but what what
you know what's clearly to me i mean i
do know is that you know the prince of
wales when when he had
when he was told that you know some five
years ago to take on greater
responsibility given the state of the
the health of the duke of edinburgh then
and the queen herself you know he was
already planning his kingship and and
once very much it wanted that point very
much harry and william to be part of
that that moved towards a new monarchy i
actually think that he still believes in
that pierce how how he can actually
bring that about i don't know i don't
think anybody no it's i mean it'll be
fascinating what happens i mean if harry
brings this book out and it spray guns
the royal family all over again as he
did with the oprah interview i mean all
hell's going to break loose and i think
it would be very disloyal towards his
father who from what i'm told is
completely bemused about why his son has
turned rogue on him well listen we had
this discussion a few days ago and i and
i sort of i hesitated on the decision i
said there should be a reflection and i
i himself had a reflection appears i i
do think that now given all that's
happened in the last 10 days i think
harry really should be considered about
actually sort of ending this story and
say look this book isn't the right idea
yeah because what's it going to do it's
going to cause a great deal of hurt a
great deal of debt i just think they
should stop talking about the royals
they've left the country they've left
royal duty they apparently wanted
freedom and privacy and yet all they do
is constantly give interviews or public
statements or podcasts or books whatever
it may be in which they trash their
family and the monarchy and at some
point you've got to think why are you
doing this how are you getting happiness
or freedom i continue to do it i mean
you know
they made the queen's life more
difficult in her last two years
you know
philip had died and she was in ill
health she must have been hating what
they were doing uh to the to the brand
of the royal family so i just don't get
what they think their endgame is other
than enriching themselves but at what
cost of their happiness well i think a
lot of people share your view peers and
i'm actually moving that way what the
one thing that harry and megan lack
is a good advisor it's somebody to sort
of really they've got american los
angeles
publicist but that's not good enough
because you know they're at in it for
their own ends yeah i mean but it needs
an advisor someone with with a real
knowledge and understanding of what the
king himself is
the real shame of it is
if they had just carried on in the same
vein they did up to their wedding well
they were very popular in this country
and they represented a very different
more diverse couple in the royal family
and they were getting great credit and
praise for that if they carried on
just being
as they were then i think they'd have
been very popular and quite beloved
members of the family and could now be
real weapons for king charles to take
the monarchy forward with a slightly
more youthful and diverse way as it is
they're sort of running this rival royal
family over in california and it's
causing constant friction anyway we'll
see how that all washes up ken great to
see you i often think about you with
these things because you were around
them all when they were all kids and i
think that you know and i know diana
would have hated the fact the boys
aren't talking she would have been i
think really distraught by it yeah but i
mean i sort of have fond memories of
working at that time and you know i i'm
coming more around to your view on this
piers but but i do think that that that
that harry
is unhappy with his situation yeah i do
think now particularly because he's been
here and i think he realizes that this
is where he should be and i i know deep
down that his father wants him to be
part of this new movement in this new
monarchy